[Aplausos]
el ala dura republicana se resiste a
darle el voto a Kevin mccarthy y por el
momento no logra convertirse en el
presidente de la cámara de
representantes es la primera vez en Cien
años que un nominado a este cargo no
consigue Que los representantes de su
propio partido voten por él la falta de
consenso ha hecho que sus partidarios se
enfrenten para buscar los votos
suficientes
mucho más gente ha tomado el dinero de
Kevin mccarthy para ser elegido y luego
hay unos cuantos que no quieren apoyarle
Como portavoz así que imagínate Esto no
es nada sobre el país se trata de Kevin
Simplemente no les gusta Kevin Mccartney
El desafío es su postulación comenzó
cuando uno de los representantes
republicanos propuso a Andy Beach como
portavoz un congresista de freedom cocus
que está alineado con las políticas de
Donald Trump al menos 19 conservadores
decidieron dejar de apoyar a mccarthy
quien necesita 218 votos en la cámara de
representantes y hasta el momento ha
obtenido 203 en medio del caos los
demócratas nominaron a
primera afroamericano que asumirá la
vocería de La minoría en la cámara
el escrutinio coincide en que el número
total de votos emitidos es de 434
de los cuales el honorable hamín del
estado de Nueva York ha recibido 212
el honorable Kevin mccarthy del estado
de California ha recibido 203 los
republicanos de la cámara de
representantes están ansiosos por
enfrentarse a la agenda del presidente
Joe biden tras dos años de control del
partido demócrata de ambas cámaras del
congreso pero hasta este miércoles se
sabrá si podrán unificar su voz como
partido de oposición